ah fine why sticking out my tongue looks
like I'm trying to touch people that I'm
not that both hey what is going on
YouTube now too frequently in my life
haven't met this type of person that I
hate the most
now what is this type of person you ask
this type of person is a backstabbing
disloyal [ __ ]
these brother loyal oh now what I'm
fighting out them when it comes to a lot
of people nowadays loyalty really
doesn't mean [ __ ] to you now how many of
you out there have the hardest time
finding a little homie you know I'm
saying like a loyal down-to-earth
homeboy or homegirl and how many of you
out there have brought somebody into
your inner circle that you really
thought was the true homie but they done
backstabbed up [ __ ] out your I hate
disloyal [ __ ] like what the hell
happened like loyalty used to be the
thing that everybody was looking for in
a friend or a human being and don't get
it twisted I'm not talking about blind
loyalty either like if you follow
somebody to the ends of the earth even
if you know that they're wrong no [ __ ]
that the loyalty that I'm talking about
is staying true to your homies people
don't give two [ __ ] shits about that
and I'm starting to understand why
because it seems that people had this
concept that as long as you come up
sacrificing everybody else along the way
you're perfectly fine doing that [ __ ]
and through those people who I've met
who have done or do that type of [ __ ]
you are what we call a trance es [ __ ]
oh you have no idea how much I love that
phrase you can see ass [ __ ] but
lick your peacock but stuffing Joe
licking [ __ ] [ __ ] ha
anybody who has done this to somebody
and has done it to them over and over
again and to the next people that meet
have done this without facing
consequences and you'll want to know why
and you want to know why it's because
when they do that type of [ __ ] nobody
checks these [ __ ] phone are you
dad and it's because what [ __ ] goes down
people love using this phrase don't
worry
karma will get them karma talking about
Carmex [ __ ] that's a chapstick I don't
another thing while yesterday I meet
this hipster [ __ ] dude he came out to
me and asked
have you heard about Carmack's it's
awesome you're coming up to me acting
like you dis now with that [ __ ] let me
tell you something your crusty ass
toenail it's been discovered black and
Asian people been known about convicts
get your ass back at home shake the damn
beer chop your man bun off and hold your
breath until you got damn it
you know sometimes I just ain't waiting
for justice because we always have to
wait there and say they're gonna get it
in their jail time and this is one of
the biggest reasons why people had the
hardest time investing themselves in the
new people as I get older I slowly start
to be at life why Drake made that song
nah no plans no no no that's not even
how it goes it is the hardest thing to
meet people who will stay true to you
and stay by your side through thick and
thin and that's why I always say keep
your circle small and know who are your
friends and who are your acquaintances
and you know what I think the worst part
about these disloyal [ __ ] is
that they are the best at being likeable
but what you'll find out is just because
somebody is likeable and pleasant to be
around it doesn't mean that you should
trust them because these type of people
do they could stab you right in the back
the day before but the day that they see
you they will come up to you with
wide-ass open arms waiting for a hug I
just wish I could pull a BART Kwan stick
my [ __ ] fingers into the socket of
their [ __ ] eyes dragged all the way
down and smash their [ __ ] chin into
my [ __ ] kneecap but no I always gotta
wait for karma because Karma's gonna get
them someday well guess what
[ __ ] Karma's a [ __ ] medal
back to your kneecap what hey what is
going on YouTube don't you hate people
huh Jesse backstab the [ __ ] out of you
and we just gotta wait to be disloyal
[ __ ] will get theirs because it
turns out they will not get their far in
life and when you better than them guess
what success is the best revenge I'll
keep my homies tight and close though
ain't nobody new up in this circle [ __ ]
deal with it but remember fans if you do
want to be a part of these vlogs make
sure that you go to the Facebook fan
page or go to the Instagram lay me on
some questions some blog topics some
articles whatever you like it will get
see all myself